we will be going over a gambit it seems
like this seems to be a theme this is
what people keep requesting next week
hopefully we will definitely do some
sort of normal mainline mainstream sort
of opening it's only fair it'll be the
last round of the tournament Danny's
gonna have to play Darian to see who
wins Monday night mayhem so they're both
here in the audience tonight but tonight
we will be going over the Aris off
gambit and this was requested by
Siddiqui Yodo Tomo and Eduardo baleen
hopefully I said at least one of those
names right but they've been requesting
it week after week so it's finally time
to give them what they've been
requesting so let's let's get to it here
so this is e 45 and now not darienne's
worst nightmare
but Bishop to c4 so this is the bishops
opening it's surprisingly even less
popular than the Kings gambit but it's a
logical enough move obviously whenever
you move this pawn now our Bishop is
looking pretty nice on this diagonal and
the main move is what we're looking
forward tonight Knight to f6 but what's
funny is this is also a secret weapon of
Michael comer so a lot of the times they
play this move just sort of
instinctually as if Wade had already
played Knight f3 and this is this is
Mike secret that I will be releasing to
the world so nobody tell Mike about this
episode he'll be he'll be somewhere
he'll be so angry he figures after this
opening he tricks people into the two
knights so and he's like alright so this
is just great for white and then he
can't wait to slam this move but did you
see that move coming Mike you see that
one coming
so he's somewhere like pulling out his
hair like d3 so that's that's one
possible way to play against it if they
play a different move order here not
Knight to f6 the other way is to play
Knight to c3 and you can follow it up
with d3 and moves like f4 try to take
advantage of the fact that you haven't
played Knight
three yet in a lot of lines sometimes
it's not even goes to e2 but tonight
will be focused on the the main line
here after Knight to f6 and now White
has a surprise in mind so not the most
popular moves which are d3 and Knight to
c3 which both protect upon and not even
Knight to f3 which is a counter attack
tonight we'll be looking at the move d4
which okay it can be quite a surprise
it's not a very popular move so you have
a the possibility to have them already
sort of make a mistake so which which
pawn are they going to take they should
probably take something and the main
move is to take on d4 it's not very good
to play Knight takes e4 it is usually
pretty easy for white to get an
advantage in several different ways
first of all we take here on e5 and
already we have some tactical tricks
based on moves such as Queen to d5 which
are threatened checkmate and the knight
in certain lines we can check first and
after the King captures back play Queen
d5 and take the knight so these sort of
tactical threats are already in the
position so for example if we put our
knight here who can find the best move
here
what would white play now
excellent
yeah Bishop takes f7 and then you pick
up the night you're up upon and the
black King has lost the right to castle
so you're doing pretty good this is much
better than Queens a d5 which looks
pretty good like are you greedy I want
to win the piece but black has this move
and if you don't capture the knight he's
gonna go to e6 in and block the f7 pawn
but if we take black and even play this
position which should be fine for him
despite appearances at first so we have
some some threats here we're gonna go
here we're gonna take this and this
should be just fine for black so much
better was a Preston's move order so
very good all right so we'll go back
here now and we'll focus on the main
line and again what's next move might
also surprise you you might be expecting
e5 but much more popular as Knight to f3
and playing a 5 is not so good in this
position sometimes like in the Scotch
this is sort of a move that you get to
play a lot but here after d5 black can
get a very nice position after the move
Bishop to c7 the point is after we take
if white goes and tries to get back his
material we have this tricky move yeah
so if Bishop c5 I assume we just take on
d5 that's still probably fine but this
also guarantees an advantage because
after you take we can go here and in
this position it's black that's way
ahead and development material is equal
but this isn't any way to get any
advantage so blacks actually doing very
well in this position which is why when
we go back here not e5 Knight f3 and so
our major focus tonight will be
unaccepting the gambit so we'll just put
this on the board just for a moment
no people are shaking their heads which
is a decent reaction
so it's that is the problem with this
too is that some people see this
position and then already they're like
well that's too much white has too much
and as we'll see that is the case in
even in in every line it seems like
white does get an advantage so sort of
this is sort of an unbeatable weapon the
ER Asaf gambit unbeatable you like oh he
likes it he likes it so let's look at
not accepting it and the most common
move here is Knight to c6 and now we've
transposed to the Scotch gambit which
we've talked about before so in in my
scotch video Aaron Lin we talked about
the move e5 the alternative is castling
Oh Aaron you left the door open you know
scary it is out there Aaron well it's a
scary world aren't you scared
don't you know there's like bad guys out
there and creepy crawlies so we've
covered this before we'll come right
back look at canceling in this position
the main line just go over it quickly
since it's it's already been covered is
after Bishop to b5 we're going over the
era sauvé gambit you are you sov will go
back to it in just a minute
okay so in this position we can take now
double the pawns and so you get this
very interesting position where black
has the two bishops obviously his pawn
structure is a little bit tattered but
uh all in all so it's a rather equal
game and sometimes in the future black
is hoping to push these guys forward and
you know get a get a good square for
this guy so a very interesting way to
play just real briefly though we'll talk
about to move castling because we
haven't talked about that yet on this
show and among the moves that Black has
available Knight takes is fine and after
rook e1
d5 excellent which would be completely
crushing for black were it not for this
trick we can take here and after the
Queen takes back hopefully everybody
sees it Knight to c3 and so this is just
a different way of playing and the main
line continues with Knight to g5
castling and you get your material back
but honestly I kind of prefer black in
this position the rook doesn't really
look entirely healthy over on e6 you
might get kicked around but it's it
should be theoretically equal
disposition so that's another way to
play and so you will probably if you do
have this as part of your your
repertoire you do need to sort of have a
back-up plan for when they play Knight
to c6 which will happen more often than
they'll accept it so I suppose one more
line and this is sort of the line that I
think a lot of or Assaf gambit players
like to pretend doesn't exist it's not a
very popular line but it's just fine for
black it's very underrated so let's just
show sort of the basics here the main
move is to take back but if you're a big
fan of the Danish gambit or The Goring
gambit you could castle here which is
pretty suspicious but you know after the
following moves I don't know I think I'd
rather be white in a tournament now
objectively black is probably winning
here but that's not so easy to prove
when you're sitting down at a tournament
you've never seen this before so for a
certain type of people this may may
appeal to them but the main move is to
take and now there's quite a lot of
moves like every Bishop move is a move
we'll go over just one briefly here so
after here you can consider either a
five or castling ie five is the more
popular if you Castle and everybody
castles and then you play e5 now d5 and
okay I mean you get sort of a balanced
game if you try to be a little more
direct with the move e5 again d5 this is
sort of the automatic reaction and now
if you take
you get this end game where again you
need to make the decision you know
should I take the Queen should I take on
g7 should I play Queenie to check so
which yeah which one you take the Queen
and then take upon okay we'll go over
this line which is probably even better
than Queenie too though they're so
similar for time we'll just go over one
so this is sort of the one of the main
positions Bishop h6 and yet so you get a
position like this where obviously your
jeep on is looking pretty good
that's sort of annoying but also there's
like a four on two over on the Queen
side so all in all this should be quite
an equal position so yeah you can choose
for yourself of this as sort of the the
way you want to play this is a variation
that you would need to know but really
this should be directly entirely equal
okay so now we're gonna jump to our
first game here and this is the game
between Nicolay
semmen semenovich tereshchenko one of
your favorite I'll pronounce like one
name right like all of tonight versus
George rot Louie from 1909 and we'll go
over three games tonight so let's see
what happens when they accept the gambit
first of all half of the class shakes
their head mm-hmm but okay you still
have to prove what you're gonna do here
is white you would just castle here so
if you castle I could play here I can
still play Knight to c6 okay you might
get your your pawn back if you want it
and then I'll castle this also should be
a mm-hmm so here yeah you're playing
rook e1 after Bishop c5 what d1 and if
here
suppose I should protect my name okay
and I'm castling you know you have a
substantially different game so this
also is probably a possible line but in
general people like to immediately go
for it they take on d4 they put the
question to the knight and really you
only have one good retreat square Knight
to f6 and all like the other analysts
they always analyze like all these other
bad knight moves that just like lose
immediately for some reason but the
obvious choice and almost the only move
that's ever been played is Knight to f6
yeah correct yeah what just gets a huge
you know lead in development but black
is up a pond so this is the challenge
you know can you prove that you can get
an attack going with your lead here or
am I just gonna be up a pond and there
are in general three different plans
that black can embark upon in this
position white it's really easy to play
white because the plan is always the
same the plan is you put the knight on
c3 you put the bishop on g5 you Castle
queenside and you bring your last rook
into the center so you do that basically
against anything that black does black
on the other hand can play lines with
Knight to c6 and then follow it up
either with d6 or Knight to c6 followed
by d5 those are two main ideas and then
move c6 followed by d5 which at first
looks like it's really slow but that's
actually the critical line in this
variation so you can even postpone you
know developing your pieces in favor of
c6 and d5 so first game we're gonna look
at will cover one of these plans where
the knight goes to c6 and the pawn goes
to d5 now in this position okay there's
actually the most common move here is
Bishop to g5 which is inaccurate and
we'll go over that at the start of our
next game because that's what was played
in that game but to give you the short
answer why it's because if you play
Bishop to g5 then black can sometimes
play Knight to c6 followed by defy
and stop you before you have an attack
so you put the knight on c3 so you have
control over d5 and in this game Knight
to c6 which at first looks great you get
to attack the Queen maybe she'll just go
back home but you actually swing over to
a really aggressive square Queen to h4
alright Bishop to e7 and as per the plan
Bishop to g5 now we're gonna figure out
which square the pawn is gonna go to and
in this game he chose the move d5 now
obviously this is sometimes a liability
sometimes we'll be able to take your
deep on especially because I you know
we're about to get all both of our rooks
right in the center of the board and
then there's pins everywhere so I guess
what would you guys play here as white
yeah excellent yeah if your first
instinct is like your Bishop is attacked
and need to retreat it this might not be
the opening for you because yeah you
need to just play as actively as
possible so you Castle queenside and
okay Bishop to e6 sorry bishop - yeah
Bridget to e6 which protects the pond
one more time and now rook to e1 okay
and probably the best move here for
black is the castle but he made a
typical mistake that happens all the
time in these lines to move h6 which
threatens nothing if you take my bishop
than your rook is hanging so due to the
pin there's really no threat here and
actually he's already in trouble but
White has to find one really difficult
move here if he wants to get a small
advantage so I'll challenge the class
this is a very complicated position you
know there's pins on the D and E file
there's everything can take everything
you know all sorts of pieces can take
all sorts of stuff so I'll challenge the
class and this one you may want to pause
your videos for at home it's it's not
not an easy solution so so best to look
the night takes d5 seems like it's sort
of like the most natural move you could
play in the position but actually I can
get away with just taking this night and
did you have up okay and now I can take
back this way okay so yeah you've traded
quite a lot of stuff which is it's fine
for me as black because I'm trying to
not die here it's not a move that you
would first consider the best move here
is Bishop takes d5 which yeah you're
close yeah something takes d5 and the
point is now after Knight takes does
anyone want to guess how you'd follow-up
Knight takes so I still have Knight
takes I take care check yeah it's check
but actually in this position you have
the more brilliant move rook takes d5
and after this capture here check
there's actually two ways to capture
they both give you an advantage now
Knight takes is probably objectively the
strongest even though every other
analysts says rook takes in preparation
for this I studied this position for
like an hour last night which way is
better to take so it's not the best use
of my time but I do I do weird things
the threat here though you play Queen h3
next and yeah you tend to win some stuff
you know his Queens gonna move away
either to e7 or or f6 and then you play
Queen h3 also this I guess I don't have
it here but this also is a very strong
continuation the point is you've
prevented black from castling because if
you castle this would just be a disaster
so both captures are good enough to give
away an advantage but obviously very
difficult to see over the board it's
something that you know it's it's it's a
lot easier when you have an engine help
you out because these lines get really
complicated
and really fast but in the game he did
play this move that was suggested which
is an okay move it's not it's not bad
so after here white played Queen to h5
and I think black didn't see the threat
that's what you wanted to do mm-hmm
and I think black just didn't see the
threat the threat is just to take this
bishop so and I just think he didn't see
it because in the game
he took here on c3 which loses very
quickly but the rest of the game is so
pretty it's really funny what happens
next so well we'll get to that however
black has one move to get an advantage
here and this one might even be harder
to find than the last puzzle so what's
the only move black can play to secure
an advantage here and the surprising
move is King f8 the point is you're
threatening g6 to trap the Queen so
that's why if you castle do you wouldn't
be able to play g6 but after King f8
white should take this pond even though
after g6 now the Queen is trapped but
now we take the bishop and when you take
we take your Queen taking back both ways
make sense but let's use all of our
pieces and after this capture if you
play rook takes six then King f7 will
win material so instead you can take
here black can protect this pawn and
black has emerged with a slightly better
position so alright it's an exchange
White has a pawn for the exchange but
all in all this should be favorable for
black though you had to find King f8
just to get this calculate all of that
correctly to get a small advantage but
in the game black simply blundered and
so I've just been thinking all week did
he just not see rook takes e6 I assumed
he just didn't see it I assumed he
didn't calculate that it worked somehow
because Network takes six and you're in
a lot of trouble
but the game is great so he just played
rook takes the stuff then he plays rook
takes the stuff the Queen moves rook
takes the stuff now you're threatening
rook d8 and you know getting out of the
way and after g6 rook takes the stuff so
it takes the stuff or it takes the stuff
or pics of stuff rook takes the stuff
and after you this capture well now it's
it's just over and I do like that white
did play the most accurate mate in this
position so I'm able to show you guys
otherwise enchantress throw this game in
the garbage but after the most accurate
moves black gave it up you know seeing
that this is his only move in this
position so yeah we can see and it's
sort of one of the problems was h6
doesn't really threaten anything but you
can kind of get a feeling that no matter
what it's always very difficult to find
the absolute best moves in these
positions but in general it's it's just
a lot easier to play white and okay this
game black just missed a threat and then
the game was what's over immediately all
right this next game is Yaakov Isaiah
vich Knight hatched versus no-name from
1950 so who do you suppose one okay so
we get back to this position so you're
wondering how we got here in this
position d4 and after the capture Knight
to f3
and we're looking at what happens when
they accept and we'll go back to this
position here is sort of our starting
position and in this game will look at
when black develops a plan of Knight to
c6 and d6 instead of d5 which okay also
isn't the most active but we're trying
to consolidate and we don't want d5 to
be a liability so in this game Bishop to
g5 which was played first and also it's
kind of interesting about this gambit to
is it's so old that there's like a lot
of inaccuracies are the main line and
the reason this is inferior to the
immediate Knight to c3 can be seen in
the following variation after Knight to
c6 if your Queen tries to go to the
aggressive square on each for now d5 and
the problem is you know we can't Castle
queenside we don't have a knight that
could take on d5 so we'd be forced
either to retreat or to take on f6 and
both lines should be fine for for black
if Bishop d3 will come back to Bishop
takes f6 then there's like a thousand
really complicated ways that you can get
an advantage with black there's so many
complicated ways you can play like night
before you can play Bishop before
followed by Queen e7 you can play Queen
e7 immediately but even like this simple
move Bishop to e7 also just gives black
the advantage much is this the same way
as this does we just we Castle and we're
up on up you know maybe perhaps this is
a slightly better try you at least
double the pawns which gives you some
hope for compensation here but this was
the move played in tartakower
rory's from 1905 and you guys have heard
of tartakower but he lost this game as
white now in the game his opponent just
played Bishop to e6 but even better to
get a larger advantage was Queen to e7
to misplace the White King and then
Bishop to e6 which blacks upon white has
absolutely no compensation
he has negative compensation okay so
returning that's why in in this position
here Knight to c3 is more
at least nowadays but in this game
his opponent just played Bishop to e7
allowing wait to get his Knight to c3
okay so castles and then white castled
but which way Aaron which way did White
Castle queenside excellent and after
Knight to c6 the Queen went all the way
over and in this game we'll be looking
at d6 alright and it's actually kind of
interesting here so perhaps your first
thought is sort of this this obvious
move but it does allow one defensive
resource for black namely Bishop to f5
which might be okay you actually get
sort of an unclear position whenever you
put this rook on a1 you always want to
be thinking about taking this Bishop
we're gonna come back though and see a
more accurate movement than rook e1 but
in this position okay you can try this
you can take it and it looks like you
can't take back with the Queen because
of Knight d5 but that also might be a
playable line but perhaps better is this
and after some captures we can move our
Bishop back we're getting ready to play
Knight to f5 if we can trade the Queens
we're not going to get checkmated and so
this should be sort of unclear but
obviously white as compensation for the
exchange however you can prevent that
entire idea of Bishop to f5 with the
move Bishop to d3 which was played and
now you're threatening to take on f6 and
then take on h7 and in the game black
decided to defend with the move h6 which
isn't very good but neither is g6 if you
play g6 it's also it's also good for
giving you an idea of how easy it is for
white to attack you play rook to e1 and
you're threatening to take the bishop
which happened in the game Haas clot
from 1997 yeah he didn't find the best
move which is to prevent you from taking
the bishop
instead he played here and and now the
game is is over after this move so the
game didn't last very much longer than
this absolute of the recapture we take
on f6 and among other good moves I mean
Knight to d5 threatening c7 he tried to
go here and then he made it even worse
on himself in this position like he's
already gonna lose a lot of stuff but
after h5 yeah white simply went to g5
and black resigned so now he's facing
the threat of the sacrifice on g6 and
all in all that's it's already over so
all right so that's that's how quickly
things can go downhill
instead sorry better here is Bishop to
e6 which prevents me from taking on e7
and then there's two moves and it's kind
of funny
the computers disagree here both moves
have the same idea of trying to remove
the defender here because if this bishop
goes away then we get steak on e7 the
complicated way the Komodo likes starts
with Bishop to c4 the point being that
if your bishop takes on c4 we play rook
take c7 which is again very good and if
you play d5 we play Bishop takes d5 and
that works out in White's favor but you
do have this move you can try to trade
some of the pieces to alleviate the
attack and okay so and then it gives us
this is Komodos line Knight to d4 is a
good move that's kind of a nice move to
find the point is you take my bishop I
take on e7 and my Brook is really active
so this should be slightly better for
white and stock fish instead prefers
this other crazy move g4 the point is
you're gonna play Bishop to f5
the immediate Bishop f5 doesn't work
because after G takes f five things
actually work out for black but after G
for whatever you play I play Bishop to
f5 the point is that if you take and you
should take I take back with a pawn and
you can't move your Bishop or else I get
to take on e7 so this for example is the
line and now things are in which
position when a knight takes okay I
assume I'll go here
my next move might be to go here
depending on what you do yep so Queen
takes which gives you the ability to go
back and guard some of these dark
squares but now there's there's so many
good moves for me my rook is going to
come to g1 my knight can go to d5 this
guy can go to g5 where sometimes you'll
sacrifice here so for example after rook
G 195 Black has to immediately start
thinking about giving away some material
but a good example of how quickly this
can go downhill is okay among other
really good moves
there's one I I quite like in this
position that's surprisingly strong
Knight to d4 the idea is if you don't
take my knight this is where my knight
is going if you do take my knight
I'm taking with my bishop and now my
queen is going to f6 and if you block
this way then you're gonna be
annihilated after I remove your bishop
and I get access to h8 so here you'd
just be getting mated so yeah things
things really go well in White's favor
in these lines it's but okay that's sort
of a good move g4 that's a nice move to
to find so I don't play a 4 ok so going
back to the game he prevented Bishop to
f5 and h6 was tried and in so many games
whenever they're castled and they played
h6 the only thing to even think about is
taking that pond so that's sort of
automatic in this position in the game
he took the bishop which isn't good but
neither are any tricks based on just
moving this Knight so you might be
thinking okay well I take he takes back
but maybe I have some sort of tricky
Knight move that I could play I will try
two of them but anywhere that night goes
well we can just we got our pawn back
and we're still attacking you we have
threats on h7
okay so something like this we got our
our stuff back 986 and yeah so I got my
stuff back and your pieces are still
misplaced so okay we can even just play
a simple move and it's it's not really
easy for you to even develop your pieces
but this should be better for white as
is going to h7 so similarly we want to
put our our guy back here but the night
would take us so we take the knife and
then we play here and okay again we're
we're just better here even in a
position like this it should just be
good for the white and stuff so you must
have said okay there's no tricks
I'll instead take this pond so white
happily took here and in the game he
went here okay it's fair enough no
there's a lot of lot of things we could
consider probably the simplest is this
Knight to g5 we want something to go
here so he took the bishop which is good
because now the bishop won't go to h7
but it's bad because now the rook will
go to g3 so he tried this defensive
resource which is a typical defense and
okay he just he plopped his bishop back
there and then I assumed this move
really stunned black because white
hasn't knockout blow now in this
position so we'll test the audience once
again Knight takes f7 it's probably good
now this also is probably very good I
can't if I take with the King mm-hmm
and I'm running away this also looks
quite good just run backwards forwards
mm-hmm will you be a five is a bit
annoying but yeah this I mean I should
this has to be good for you too yeah I
mean you can play like you're playing
here okay uh so that that's a good move
to but this move just wins on the spot
the move that he play it it's just an
instant instant killer here yeah
excellent
ninety-six which made black resign
because either you're letting me not
taking my night and I checkmate you or
you you take this and I'm still
checkmating you know yeah so 96 is just
a quick and easy kill though there's a
lot of moves that are winning because
White's crushing in here okay but now
we'll come on to the most testing plan
the line that's theoretically the most
critical and this was the highest rated
game in which this opening was played
this is the game between two people we
actually have a chance of having heard
of Boris avrech versus Almere a strip
chenko and this was played in 2001 in
Linares so again we get our our game in
there and you've got it all written down
you know the opening were you trying to
write it down and we're doing it one
more time this your last chance II 45
Bishop c4 and after Knight to f6 the
surprising move d4 you know you got the
rest
and then and then what is white play
yeah he takes d4 and then what is y play
I think so too
Knight f3 and then if they take this
what does white play okay d4 okay okay
and so black went back and in this game
we'll see the the strongest plan in
blacks best attempt to equalize this
position which is the move c6 and d5
okay so after Knight to c3 the best move
c6 and once again we put all our pieces
on just the normal locations and after
d5 what move would we play here as Wyatt
so some people see their bishops
attacked and want to move and other
people just want to castle so yeah we
there's no threat here hopefully
hopefully that goes without much
explanation and after Bishop to e7 so
perhaps now once again we are thinking
about taking your bishop we can get away
with the move rook H to e1 which wasn't
played though this is the most popular
line so we'll take a look at it the
point is of course since we pinned your
bishop this is no longer an option so if
they could easily get tricked especially
if this is a blitz game or something
they might just take that but yeah you
always have to factor in all these pins
on the D any file in the game he
preferred Queen to h4 which also has the
benefit of you can't take my bishop and
it avoids some of the problems that I
guess white might face if he plays this
line now the main move here is Bishop to
e6 and black can go without castling for
a while our plan is to always prevent
you from taking this bishop which occurs
in like every line and we're just going
to put this guy on d7 we've got all our
pieces out and then we will be
threatening your Bishop so the main line
is Queen h4
now you've got all your pieces out and
you are threatening our bishop so Bishop
to d3 and now Knight to c5 so this is
the the main main line and okay normally
we put our night here on d4 and then in
blitz we always pull Danny by putting
like all of our pieces here and you can
never take them for some reason and then
Danny gets really confused
but even this move is an attempt for
black to try to have liquidate some of
the material but even in a position like
this if you have to play g6 white is
just better so this is the main mainline
and white has lots of different plans
you can do this he can shock everybody
by going here with with any one of these
pieces actually and if if you take back
all sorts of bad stuff happens like
what's like we can go here and here and
then really bad stuff happens to you as
black it's quite a quite a crushing move
and obviously if you don't take then you
know we're jumping in here and here and
so yeah it's so it is hard to be black
in these these lines but this is the
best you can do everybody should be
playing this is white because it's good
for weight so practice everich had taken
a good hard look at these lines and you
decide it all opt out of that and I'll
play Queen to h4 which has a slightly
different character to it as opponent
when here threatening the bishop
and okay we could again consider here
which has a good chance of becoming this
this was played what was played oh yeah
so this was played if you play Bishop to
d3 excuse me then you can transpose to
what we just saw with the following
moves so this would would again be the
main line so he avoided that by leaving
his bishop hanging and okay his opponent
went for it he took up the challenge he
said alright I'll take your bishop
alright so where's where is the
compensation
well these rooks are fantastic that's
about as good as your rooks get so he
decided he'd take care on f6 there's
only one serious way you can take back
and now this is kind of good because
this is what we'll be doing tomorrow for
my strategy class it'll be maneuvering
our pieces how to improve your pieces
and it seems kind of odd to sacrifice a
bishop and then do a really slow
maneuver but that's what he did here you
know the the bishop yeah he moved
maneuvers all the way to f5 he gave away
a piece and then you're saying I have
the time to reposition my guys an even
better square which is exactly what
happened now your bishop is under attack
so the bishop went to c5 alright so how
are we gonna continue here with white
and what's funny is when you play
White's next move the computer
immediately gets really really angry
like ah it's like minus two blacks just
crushing it rook takes Knight what's
what's the point behind this move I'll
take this with something
okay but then when you let the computer
and think about whites move eventually
it's like a zero zero zero zero and then
you keep putting the moves in the game
there were all the top choices it's like
oh it's winning so though it's very
complicated
the computer is it really didn't like
that movie I wanted rookie four which is
coming so at some point we're gonna lift
this rook sometimes we'll be threatening
to take here sometimes we'll be able to
just swing this guy over all sorts of
threats but here's a really good square
for the Queen where you're protecting
your knight and yeah now you're a rook
is ready to come in rookie four all
right
and rookie four as promised
so black has to somehow get counterplay
the move the computer was first afraid
of was here but then it must have not
seen this move that white has white now
has a brilliant move based on so this
isn't the game now this is the the
computers line that it first thought was
really good for black and the all-star
move that white has now g3 also is fine
that's yes a second choice but you can
put your hook on d4 and you you you um
you want the rook hit you want it if you
take it we go here and that's your how
are you going to stop me from meeting
you so you can't take you could try this
move Queen to b6 but now we go here and
you have lots of issues we're
threatening mate if you okay take care
check which okay that looks pretty scary
you have to allow this as white your
checks will get you nowhere you can
check me again but I'll take your Bishop
I'll run to g3
everything's fine conversely if you
don't do that which is the fastest way
to stall the mate if you play a move
like rook g8 there's a you can just take
it excellent yeah I mean I assume rook
e8 is also winning okay just pinning the
rook but this is is the cleanest and the
fastest no here yeah and then that's
that's curtains so yeah fantastic stuff
so even the computer was wrong in its
initial assessment in the game Queen to
b6 was played with a threat and in white
side yeah what on the left side what
what's the threat okay thank goodness we
got one of our strongest players here
yeah so that is the threat so b3 was
played all right so who's attack is
gonna be faster
and now already there's there's some
temptations here as we hear he played he
would so it's very tempting to take this
it's very tempting you were not tempted
at all
this is tempting the point is you take
back yep because you see that it's a
draw is that why what are you gonna do
okay but now this move g4 so now I'm
threatening rook h6 so you have to see
blacks defense here
Bishop to f8 but again you might be
thinking okay now if I can only put a
knight on h4 it would be mate so I go
here alright now I have a threat what
are you gonna do about that Queen takes
f2 excellent
I guess this this is why you saw this
from the beginning you know like that's
why I'm not even tempted how come you
didn't say oh yeah Queen takes up - no
no big deal
the point is after here you must take
but you're down to pieces so there's
nothing better but to repeat so yeah I
mean this is very tempting mate that's
obviously why you have your your queen
and rook right where they are
but you had to see you know past several
defensive moves and so that would have
would have cost white half a point
yeah precedent Smith would have played
that one second
whether it worked or not yeah it doesn't
always work but white instead played the
strongest move which is Queen takes f7
with lots and lots of threats but now
it's blacks turn to make a make a nice
little threat here we're threatening
matin to Queen a3 Queen B - so you have
to play the right move here with white
so again I'll let the audience decide
the best move here is rook takes d7
because it's the last thing darien would
have ever thought about okay so
threatening mate and now I have an
escape square so now I can run away so
he tried this check queen a3 also gets
you nowhere because now I can just run
away and okay but now what do you do is
black why isn't he taking this rook he
takes f6 with me to follow which was
played okay and continue the attack you
find this next move with white you'll
win the game yeah yeah right so this
this fails and then oh you came so close
you came so close okay but only you have
to find just one more move and polish
off your your big attack here
like g5y a rookie a threatening two
different mates with the Queen here and
so black resigned if let's just say
Queen to g6 let's try to understand why
we resigned you take on g8 and you take
on f6 which will lead to a big checkmate
here so as you can see deras off gambit
is not at all as suspicious as the Kings
gambit that we've been been covering
with some of those lines it's actually a
very good weapon for white and although
it's unlikely that they'll accept it
because just judging by the audience
everyone was too scared normally you
won't accept that and unless you're
prepared but if you're prepared you'll
also know that it's pretty good for
white but it is good just as sort of the
backbone of your repertoire you can have
it you can aim for it but you should
know other lines that also are possible
it within the the bishops opening all
right well thanks everybody for coming
out we had a really good class tonight
pretty exciting line hit like share
subscribe and thanks everybody for
coming out
you